hello I into work of this video playing
dim ICC so five okay scratch I go with
my line my score is just too good yet to
abandon it even though I know that it is
not the best line ever I think this is
still correct him age three and now it
was its castle so i cannot remember i
think it is castles
I a g4 queen age four yes yes yes SS I'm
getting I'm getting there yeah this is a
position whereby it might be better but
it is far from easy to play a play
there's lots more space but he also with
all this space he is some sometimes
suffering from ya overextending himself
a little bit ok d 54 I don't know d
favim I just take this is what I'm what
what irritates me ok maybe have a look
at it be porn if he castles Bishop e3
huh but I have he's got ripped it to
probably probably not that grade
just castled short it's a simple
solution not a bad one probably so just
this my night on UHF my night there what
does my night doing yeah I don't know
probably g 6 97 96 this kind of thing
check okay you know what's got more
space but I'm so quite solid
yeah I need to trade stuff maybe it's
got night at five now no I didn't do it
okay so it's going with this is it is
that so dangerous I don't know so feel
reasonably solid maybe I'm just too much
of an optimist and chest sometimes
Quincy foil might be the trick why trick
is wrong with idea in see if I this is
be five I guess and now we place it I
kind of speculated that it didn't do it
before and they won't do it I would do
it now maybe this is a move I know it
looks lucky with be five but f Queen f7
for potential rugae to and after the
home I thought this isn't so much of a
problem
okay aight takes takes takes g6 takes on
f6 spoon okay if you ever want to see a
position where where there's a bad
bishop you have to look at this game
it's funny question is however can you
break through I mean
I don't know maybe maybe there is no way
for him to to actually win h5 you might
take I can go here made my pledge form
okay I think I'm going for this if it
takes the rook takes I have root edge
flow also to attack your form one funny
thing is that if you have a good Bishop
you sometimes actually have problems
defending pawns okay this i'm taking
luke cage for we can take afore he takes
this b6 this is a problem the be pawn
gets very very dangerous so probably
have to go to hear rook 87 King da to be
six damn check
check can i play for when your side
completely ridiculous probably ESO hi
morning thinking about drug a seven
kings ii eight but again be six is the
move okay ch4 we have 654 I don't know
it's a bit of a gamble check
check check okay that gamble actually
actually paid off check check check
check check check check white forfeit
hmm I don't know the draw maybe well
yeah what a very tough game where I was
essentially lose the whole way but try
to try to defend him okay so yeah I know
this line is kind of questionable but
I'm still sticking to it Jim white is
better all the way check okay I'm
actually plundering it you can do this
and win stuff hmm ok I guess you just
saw this which is also looking ok
I've and maybe I should just take him
yeah this is system of better here I'm
actually quite happy with the G file I'm
quicker on the G file and hip there's my
chick yeah that's not so bad for you ok
so went back ok it looks bad but maybe
I'm not losing i mean yeah i think i
thinkI this should be a draw check check
ok t I'll it starts to get tricky check
I'm very nice both h4 given by the comp
may I cannot take age for ya so if i
take this there's check the promotion
your pawn takes the splendor in the roof
so I have to do this this this ok I
think I'm always ready to stop the porn
you know the king is near it this is a
drawing us check check no Tim I'm going
better maybe winning check out and do
engine like my plate rack
six oh my god okay i was getting hectic
of course at the time was was getting
getting low but still 26 should be
within my abilities to see okay i hope
you liked this fight thanks for watching